6 вересня після літньої перерви в окружному суді Гааги
відновляться судові слухання у справі про збитий малайзійський "боїнг",
який виконував рейс MH17.
Суд розглядає справу по суті з червня цього року.
Наступна частина судового процесу може стати найбільш емоційною,
адже виступатимуть родичі загиблих - близько 80 осіб.
Родичі розкажуть суду про те, як катастрофа рейсу MH17
і втрата близьких відбилась на їхньому особистому житті.
У кожного своя історія. Але родичі можуть висловлюватися,
наприклад, і про представлені докази, і про позицію захисту.
У результаті катастрофи в небі над Донбасом 17 липня 2014 року
загинули 298 осіб.
Плуг втратив трьох членів сім'ї - старшого брата, невістку і племінника.
Сам він планує виступити в суді в листопаді, коли буде завершено
представлення всіх доказів. Процес проти трьох росіян і одного українця
в судовому комплексі "Схіпхол" неподалік аеропорту Амстердама
почався в березні 2020 року. Йому передувало майже шестирічне
міжнародне розслідування, яке дійшло висновку, що "Боїнг" збили з території,
підконтрольної сепаратистам, ракетою з комплексу ППО "Бук",
привезеного з Росії. Москва свою причетність до катастрофи заперечує.
На лаві підсудних заочно перебувають громадяни Росії Ігор Гіркін (він же Стрєлков),
який називав себе в 2014 році міністром оборони самопроголошеної "ДНР",
його підлеглі Сергій Дубинський і Олег Пулатов,
а також громадянин України Леонід Харченко.
Слідство вважає, що проти них зібрано достатньо доказів.
Слідство щодо інших можливих підозрюваних триває.
Всі четверо заперечують свою провину.
Процес перебуває приблизно в середині, пізньої осені очікується
заключне слово обвинувачення, а потім - захисту.
Вирок можливий не раніше кінця весни наступного року.
Але, цілком ймовірно, процес триватиме значно довше.
У разі, якщо будь-яка зі сторін вирішить подавати апеляцію, що є цілком імовірним,
то, можливо, все триватиме ще кілька років.
У разі визнання провини обвинувачених їх можуть засудити, крім позбавлення волі,
до виплат компенсації моральної шкоди родичам.
Рішення про це суду ще належить ухвалити. Як пояснила Маріке де Хун,
близько 290-та родичів подали заяви на компенсацію в середньому
від 40 до 50 тисяч євро за жертву.
За її словами, якщо підсудні не заплатять,
цю суму може виплатити уряд Нідерландів.
Маріке де Хун зазначила, що процес йде проти тих, хто, на думку обвинувачення,
несе відповідальність за доставку "Бука" на місце запуску ракети
і за здійснення пострілу з нього.
За твердженням обвинувачення, четверо підозрюваних несуть
відповідальність за те, що "Бук" прибув у те місце, звідки був зроблений запуск.
Але для суду не так важливо, хто насправді натиснув на кнопку.
Важливо, хто взагалі створив передумови для натискання кнопки.
Піт Плуг каже, що для родичів "важливіше знати, хто в підсумку
несе відповідальність за те, що був збитий "Боїнг",
хоча і прізвища тих людей, які натиснули кнопку, їх теж цікавлять:
Сподіваюся, що ми дізнаємося більше про тих, хто несе за це відповідальність,
і про людей, які збили літак, хто натиснув на кнопку.
Ми хочемо це знати. І сподіваємося, що слідство триватиме доти,
доки не встановить усіх підозрюваних.
Піт Плуг сподівається, що стануть відомі імена на самій верхівці -
тих, хто ухвалював принципове рішення. Свої висновки Піт Плуг вже зробив:
Судять чотирьох, але абсолютно ясно, що систему "Бук" надала Росія,
і в підсумку, думаю, відповідальність за все це несе російська держава.
І дуже важливо, щоб світ про це дізнався.
Очільник фонду жертв катастрофи MH17 також нагадав,
що крім процесу в Гаазькому суді проти чотирьох підозрюваних,
Нідерландами і Україною також подано позов проти Росії
до Європейського суду з прав людини.